Welcome, everybody, to another Zoom call.
I have a bunch of questions that everybody submitted.
And remember, if you forgot to submit a question or you think of something as we go,
you can actually chat it in or if you want to wait till the end of all these questions.
And then you can unmute yourself and speak it in whatever you like.
Or you can unmute yourself and sing it in.
Put it in a little tap as a song to it, and that makes it a little more entertaining.
Sorry. All right, let's get started.
Remember that your announcements are on your members' site.
And remember, also on the homepage of the members' site, if you scroll down past the announcements,
you see our lower fee for visits with me, too.
And you can self-schedule if you want other there as well.
Don't self-schedule on the main web, because that is the fee for the members.
Let's get to the questions.
Okay, so question about someone who's going to start Kibo.
Should I take supplements on Kibo Day?
Should I stop coffee enemas after Kibo at all?
So should I stop? Should I take my supplements on by Day of Kibo?
Well, usually your Kibo and food fusion is going to be typically at the morning.
And it may last anywhere from a couple hours to half the day.
I suggest you don't take your supplements in the morning before you go and do your infusion,
but you can certainly take your afternoon supplements if you're feeling up to it.
If you're feeling sick that afternoon,
and you don't feel like you could keep anything down,
then I would say, don't worry about it.
Don't stress about it. Just don't take your supplements.
And wait till you feel better.
Typically, it's not the day of Kibo that you feel sick,
though everybody experiences any gila that they may experience differently.
So it's a don't take your morning supplements,
but take the afternoon when you get home from your infusion if you can.
Should I not do a coffee enemma?
Well, I would say don't do a coffee enemma at least the day of Kibo.
You could skip the coffee enemma the next day, too.
But then go back to doing your coffee enemas again.
You could wait a maximum of two days between the coffee enemas.
Now, if you're only doing a couple coffee enemas a week,
just wait a few days after the coffee enemma.
Meeting after the Kibo infusion meeting.
Don't do a coffee enemma the day of Kibo.
Maybe don't do a coffee enemma the next day.
But then go back to doing your coffee enemas.
Next question.
Curious if the mudwig protocol is valuable.
How do you do it if you are restricting dairy?
We've got this question a lot.
I think the mudwig protocol can be valuable,
but I have some people doing the mudwig protocol because it tested on them with the cheek swab test.
But can you do the mudwig protocol if you're not supposed to be taking dairy?
And my answer to that is no, you can't do the mudwig protocol if you're restricting dairy.
Now, if on your cheek swab test,
I just put limit dairy, then we should have a specific conversation,
whether I think that would be okay for you to do if you feel led to do that.
But if on your cheek swab test, it says no dairy,
then I would say, let's not do the mudwig protocol right now.
Now, if you talked to mudwig, I've said this before.
If you went on their website, it says that oil changes the dairy.
There is it's a magical thing that goes on when you add a flaxseed oil to dairy and blend it up.
It still has the qualities of stimulating growth.
It still has IGF, but what it still stimulates the pathways that could stimulate growth.
So I would say no, that doesn't make those changes.
Next question.
I discovered some molds.
I had spilled coffee the first time I tried a coffee animal in a shower.
And in the bathroom, I discovered mold and we cleaned it up right away.
Should I be concerned if there is more mold that is not visible?
The spill was right where the fluoride connects to the tub and the fluoride is a bit loose.
Should you be concerned if you find mold in this case,
where this person found it, or if you found mold underneath your sick,
or if you found mold, and you cleaned it up and you got rid of the mold?
Should you be concerned about mycotoxins?
I would say maybe, but maybe not.
Remember, mold is going to grow quite quickly.
Bold spores are free ubiquitous.
Bold is going to grow quite quickly when you have water and contact with organic material.
And grout and concrete is organic material.
Typically, mold's not going to really grow on your tile if it's glazed.
But it can grow on any wood surface, any trim wood that you have in your bathroom.
Baseboard wood trim can grow in your shower, on your grout, mold can grow.
So, should be cleaning it under a regular basis so that it doesn't.
Now, does that mean that you have mycotoxins being dispersed from that?
Well, it really depends on how long it is there and how big of a spot it is.
So, some of the things that start measurable, if you did an immunolytic slab and you put a
petri dish in the bathroom, even after finding this little bit of mold,
it's very possible that it's going to come back less than 10 parts per million,
which is negligible and you don't have to do anything about it.
So, it is extremely common that you have little spots of mold, maybe in the quarter of your
bathroom that you have to clean on a fairly regular basis, and that doesn't mean that you have a
moldy house, it doesn't mean that you have a lot of mycotoxins in your house, it doesn't need any of them.
Now, if your mycotoxin test was extremely elevated, it still doesn't mean that's where you got them.
So, it's very difficult to discern where one could have gotten mycotoxin exposure,
because mycotoxins exposure comes from so many different sources. So, it's if you have
a immunolytic test where you put the petri dishes around your house and you have spots that are
extremely high, well, then you have to try to mitigate that problem. But for the most part,
most people that do that test, it doesn't come back high. And if it did come back high,
the person already knew that they had a mold issue in their house most of the time.
So, I would say no, typically that isn't an issue, I would just keep an eye on that spot,
that's why I think it's always good to do a cursory examination of your house, look for any areas
where moisture is coming into contact with window, trim, or something else in a long period of time
where mold could start growing and trying to keep things clean. So, this is dealing with mold and
dealing with keeping mold out of your house, really is cleanliness is next to godliness, we should say
cleanliness is next to moldlessness and that can be a prevention, can really be a help. But I
wouldn't be concerned like, oh my gosh, we found mold in this spot, will I clean it up? Is that
something to be really concerned about? No, but if it persists, if something is, you know, you find a
really bad spot that you didn't know about, that you have this giant black mold growing underneath
your sink and you never noticed it, you never looked under there, it was behind something that yeah,
that can be a concern. So, those are the kind of ways that you would assess that. I received the
Mosaic test, but the protocol says to use first year into the morning, that is at least six hours old,
I cannot hold my urine for that moment, even overnight due to the cancer in my abdomen,
should I wait to do this test, it states that the urine can't be too diluted for the test to
work. No, don't wait, still just run that, let's say, okay, so I think this person is talking about,
they're having to get up and go to the bathroom every hour or two because of a mass that's in their
abdominal cavity, so they have pressure on the bladder and they can't, you know, hold it more than
a couple hours, so there's no way I'm getting six hours and I can't hold it, just run the test. If it
comes back where the creatine level is off, then they won't, then they'll, you'll get an animal
fighting, so they do a pre-test to see if the test is valid, if they reject it, then we're back to
grow zero and we have to, we'll request new kits, but just go ahead and run the test.
We are growing and using broccoli sprouts, is this a good thing? So broccoli sprouts, the benefit of
broccoli sprouts is they contain some chlorophanes. It's so chlorophaned good for every cancer.
No, it is, probably good for every cancer. Certainly the hormone-driven cancers, it's even more
specific, it's at least more research has put on those, so yes, use broccoli sprouts, it's a very
good thing. You like them, enjoy them on different foods, it's a great thing to do. Next question,
I do have access to a pulse, P-E-M-F machine, so a pulse is a brand of P-E-M-F machine that's a very
high-gouse P-M-F machine that typically only a clinic would have because they're quite expensive,
so I do have access to a pulse P-E-M-F machine at my nantrapads office, is two times per week,
or a half hour effective, or should I do more or longer sessions? So when we used to see people in
our office, cancer patients in our office, or P-E-M-F, we have a pulse P-E-M-F machine, that's the best
one of the market right now. We used to do one hour long sessions, so we do one hour long sessions,
so I think if you could get up to an hour long, I think that would be better. Of course the cost
could be a factor, is there an ad home version of P-E-M-F that would deliver similar results?
I don't want to waste money on something that won't approach the effectiveness of the pulse.
So the cost of a P-E-M-F machine, whether it's an ad home model or an inclinate model,
is partly based upon the Gauss output of the machine. So the pulse P-E-M-F machine put out about
30,000 Gauss. A lot of the ad home ones put out less than 1,000 Gauss, like the Beamer I think is
like 700 Gauss, the IMRS is like 7 or 800 Gauss. Most of the ad home ones are pretty low Gauss.
We can get an ad home model from a company. It's not pulse that makes it, but it's a different
company that's a good company. But it's about 7,000 to 9,000 Gauss, but it's also about 9,000
dollars. So they're expensive. So you pay basically based upon the Gauss. Now unfortunately the Beamer
that puts out only like 700 Gauss still costs about 5 to 7,000 dollars. So I don't, if you have
that or if somebody could borrow you what or use what, I still think there could be value in it. Go
ahead and use it. But I wouldn't suggest purchasing something like that. You're going to purchase
one. You have to get one that puts out at least 7 to 10,000 Gauss. The pulse PMF, they're like 35 to
40,000 dollars. So that's completely out of possibilities for most people. But the ad home ones that are
7 to 9,000 Gauss are like 9,000 dollars. You really want to invest in that. You can contact me. We
don't have on our website. I don't think. But I've sold a bunch of those to different people that
wanted to have a therapy clinic in their own house. Because you could use the pulse first. You could
use the PMF for a lot of musculoskeletal things. So you can justify purchasing it because other
family members would use it. Lots of people that have purchased that. You don't have said their
kids are athletes and their husband wants to use it at home. And as you can use it every day.
And so there's benefits to have it. But they're not cheap either. So this contact our office is
that really interests you. You recommended that I not take vitamin C supplement that I was taking is
IV vitamin C ever useful. So much is said about it online. So do add more details on why I would say
not to take a vitamin C supplement to a cancer patient. Look at the blog post that's titled
hearticid oxidative stress to kill cancer. We just start typing hearticid in our website. Search
or it'll come up and you'll see that particle vitamin C at the dose that you would be able to take
orally is going to be in an antioxidant vitamin C at a dose that you would injected to your veins
in the IV is going to be oxidative. So that's the difference. So you're looking for an oxidative here
for cancer. You don't want an antioxidant because you would be negating everything else you're doing.
So you don't want to take oral vitamin C. But could you do IV vitamin C? Well, you could. Sure. If you
want to, you could do IV vitamin C. There's no negative tips of that. I guess there are some negative.
So the only negative would be if you're doing if you're doing chemotherapy and you're getting a
port put in, then there's really no negatives to doing IV vitamin C through the port. Because the
negative to doing IV vitamin C is the vitamin C can burn your barn or can burn your vessels.
So that can be a negative for some people. They're getting IVs in their arm. It can burn their
vessels over time and it can be, it's not going to be tarpaulin, though heel, but it can be a strong
irritant. But if a person has a port because they're doing T-bo, then it's really easy to do
it through the port that you don't have that negative. There really isn't any other negatives to
IV vitamin C. So it fits with any other therapy. You could do IV vitamin C if you're doing chemo,
you could do IV vitamin C if you're doing immunotherapy. You could do IV vitamin C with any of the therapies
that we have as well. It's an oxidative therapy. And there's really no other downsides to it.
Do you know anything about Dr. Mark Circus and his cancer, conquering cancer, hope you're this?
Not really. The only thing I know about him is he has, he has done some things with sodium
bicarbonate and hydrogen medicine. He's written some little booklets about that.
That's all I really don't about that. And I don't agree with all of the things that are out there,
like sodium bicarbonate therapy. We talked about that's at baking soda therapy. So there's a natural
approach to cancer by taking baking soda orally. Now I'm not a fan of that because baking soda
is extremely alkaline and you're going to alkalize your stomach, which has a very strong potential
or if not for sure that you're going to develop H. Pylori. And that's not good. So will you be
alkalizing your body by taking baking soda? Well, I have a lot of this different blog posts and such,
but your body has buffering systems. So I don't know how much it is a
urban myth anymore, but I used to have to combat this urban cancer myth that cancer doesn't
grow in an alkaline environment. Cancer only grows in an acidic environment and there was this
big urban myth. And I don't think it's as popular anymore, but it used to be really popular 20 years ago
that people getting pH strips and testing their urine and testing their saliva. And oh my gosh,
it's too acidic. We need to get it more alkaline. And then doing things to try to alkalize their body.
And I say this is a urban myth because it has nothing to do with real physiology. So real physiology is
that you have buffering systems in your body to keep things in balance. And if a person is too acidic
or too alkaline, you can see that in their blood test. You can't see that in your pH of your urine
nor can you see that in the pH of the saliva. The pH of the urine just tells you the acidity or
alkalinity of one's urine. It has nothing to do with the acidity of alkalinity of your tissue.
Same thing with the saliva. So that using pH strips to test your urine or test your saliva,
I sure hope that nobody listening to this is still doing that thinking that they're helping their
body trying to alkalize their urine and or saliva thinking that they're alkalizing their tissues.
It's just not happening. So if you took baking soda, now if you had stomach cancer
and you did a baking soda orally, there may be some benefit to that. But if you had any other
cancer, there's really going to be absolutely no benefit to that because that's going to be
buffered before it gets into the blood. If you alkalize your blood, you die. If your blood varies
very much from a 7.35 pH, which is fairly neutral, you would die. So that's just not correct.
Now, would it be true to say that cancer itself, if you could go in there surgically, cut that
person open, go in with the pH strip and test the the dilue around the cancer, would it be acidic?
Well, quite possibly because cancer is highly metabolic and it's spewing out a lot of waste,
like anything that is droid is going to have more waste. Cell waste is dispersed outside of the
cell membrane into the extracellular space and that waste is typically going to be more acidic.
That's going to be carried away. So if a person is toxic, meaning that they're not able to get rid of
their waste, their tissue is going to be more acidic. And if you did a blood test on them, they may have
what's called metabolic acidosis. And that's measured by looking at their sodium chloride levels,
potassium levels in their blood. So it doesn't mean their blood is acid, but it's, but when you have
a variation of some metrics in the blood, that's why you want to do a comprehensive metabolic panel,
it can show metabolic acidosis. But it can also show you see metabolic
alkalosis as much as you see metabolic acidosis. So how does a person get metabolic
alkalosis or acidosis? Well, it has to do with toxicity levels and ability to get rid of toxins.
And partly, it's not always like, oh, well, by liver's back dep, well, it could be your
limb system is backed up for, you know, so the toxins are getting out of the tissues. The toxins are
toxins may be getting into the blood. They're not getting out the liver. Remember, go back to the
seven phases of detoxification. If any of those pathways are blocked, it could cause issues. So
that's what you want to look at. So doing the sodium bicarbonate therapy, meaning taking sodium
bicarbonate orally makes absolutely no physiological sense. Now, well, could I inject sodium bicarbonate
into a cancer? Well, not legally. Now, there was a Dr. Simon Cheedy who did that in Italy and he
was in prison for that. Well, it wasn't a good thing. We don't care what the authorities thought.
Well, we don't know. There, there he had some indications that it did help with different
breast cancers when he injected sodium bicarbonate around the breast cancer. But you'd have to have
pretty sophisticated clinic to do that because if you, if you put a needle into a person's breast,
if you tried to inject sodium bicarbonate into the area and you punctured the tumor itself,
could you be spreading the cancer? Yes. And there's lots of dangers to things like that.
So some of the things aren't really feasible to do as a therapy. But that's another topic.
So no, I'm not completely familiar with this person. I do know that he he's he's talked about
different therapies like iodide and things that I don't know if he's just kind of selling
brochures and books. There's another guy who he's written a lot of alternative books and they're
usually short, shorter books and he's an extremely good author. And I read several of his books.
But you have to be careful that because I read a couple of his books that were nonsense too.
But he's just taking data and trying to sell books. So you have to be careful about that too. He's
not actually a practitioner. He hasn't actually seen people. So maybe this guy is a doctor. Maybe
sees people that he's seen. He has data from his patient base and how he's treating people. So I don't
discourage you from looking up other things. But I can't give really an opinion about this person.
Next question. This is a long question. So I kept it a small font here. I have been on the
rife and supplements faithfully avoiding the pork dairy products with limited sugar and gluten as
recommended. Have promising lab results implemented the fed men protocol about 60 days ago. Recently
added red light therapy. And at 65 years of age 101 pounds, I feel absolutely great. My tumor is
as far as I know, maintaining the same size for a while now. But I still struggle with an open
wound. It is a nuisance. Is it reasonable to expect any time in the near or distant future less than a
year for the tumor to begin shrinking or do I at some point need to have someone remove it?
My theory is that my body hasn't capsulated it even though it continues to have some sort of
access to energy. Will it have to be removed so that the good tissues can start benefiting?
To counter the apparent food supply, I have intermittent fasted OMAD and have recently added
a 48 hour fast once a week with absolutely no trouble in doing so. Like I said, I feel absolutely
great. Better than when I was younger. I have been faithful, intermittent, faster for several years
way before I was either diagnosed. Of course, I'd rather not have the surgery and prefer to just
always have a none weeping bleeding marabiner tumor that is smaller. I don't have a problem with
anything except the weeping bleeding issue. So in a nutshell, what can I possibly expect going
forward to the shrinking, maintaining or removal eventually? The weeping bleeding to stop as
aside my body is moving in a positive direction. How soon is it reasonable to know whether or not I
be successful beyond how great I feel and the tumor maintaining the same size? I know the things I am
doing are secure. I hope is to keep giving my body what it needs to heal and to be healthy. I would
really like to get resolution of the open world takes full you do. Time is valuable. I recognize that.
Okay, so the only honest answer is that is the tumor shrinking or maintaining
or removal or should I get it removed eventually? Well, it depends on how patient you are number one.
Realistically, is a breast tumor when you're doing everything naturally going to shrink
what's the percentage of people that I've seen that a breast tumor does shrink and go away?
Well, for a breast tumor to go away, it wasn't how the size that it started with. I've had lots of
women that the breast tumor was hardly detectable except under ultrasound and an MRI and doing
everything natural the breast tumor wasn't detectable anymore. I've had women that they could
palpate the tumor the size of a pea and then they couldn't palpate it anymore. But I've also had
women that came to me and it was the size of a marble or larger and it never seemed to shrink
beyond a certain size. Maybe it shrunk a little bit and it stopped and it stayed that size
and it's been that way for five years. So is the purpose of treating a cancer getting it to go away?
Well, you may think it is but in reality, you really want a cancer to stop growing because a cancer
is by definition and rapidly replicating cells and if it stops rapidly replicating, then it's not
acting like cancer anymore. So we need to be
dependent on where the cancer is, we need to be content on it, just stop acting like cancer.
Now if the cancer is blocking a pathway, let's say the cancer is in the liver and it's putting
pressure on the bile duct and it hasn't grown at all but it's still putting pressure on the bile duct
and my biliary wound is elevated and it's affecting detoxification pathway through my bile to my
gallbladder to my colon, then you may have to do something about it. If it's in your breast and you
didn't have an open weeping wound, then I would say just leave it and continue the process if it isn't
getting any bigger but that's not the case here. So you have an open weeping leading wound and
but you're determined that the cancer hasn't really gotten any bigger. How long do you wait before you
do something surgically? Well, it has to do with a how patient you are and b how
how what data are you using that it isn't getting any bigger. So if it's just palpatory data, if it's
just observation of size through palpation or even if it's observation of size through an MRI or an
ultrasound, you you want to make sure that it's not continuing to grow and b, you want to make sure
if you're having any discharge or bleeding, you want to make sure that it's not affecting systemic
hemoglobin, hematocrit, red blood cell level. So if you're developing anemia and your anemia is
progressing that I say we have to go ahead. We don't have the ability to use patients. We have to make
a decision to go ahead and do surgical removal because we can't have it, you know, have you
your anemia worsened and that's going to affect you systemically. So those are the things that you
have to take in to play there in the decision making process. What is the pros and cons of debulking
a tumor? So I would put this into the category of debulking a tumor. So with breast cancer, so it
depends on pros and cons of debulking a tumor, or depending on what type of cancer it is. So if you have
with breast cancer, it's part of your body, it's in your breast, but removing the tumor if you can't
get progress another way is quickly as we want to. Or if it's affecting you systemically like I
mentioned, debulking a tumor can be beneficial because if you removed the tumor, let's say you decided
to just do a lump back to me or you decided to do a mastectomy. So you removed the bulk of the tumor.
Now all the energy that you're putting into body healing and such can be can be helping prevent
metastasis and your immune system can be helping kill circulating tumor cells that are in tissues
elsewhere. So there can be benefits to be debulking a tumor. Now depending on what where the tumors at,
there can be negatives to debulking a tumor. If the tumor is completely encapsulated and there's no
weeping, there's no issues with it. I've shared examples about lung tumors that okay, they've stayed
there still at four millimeters and this one's at eight millimeters and this one's at 1.2 centimeters
and subsequent tests have shown no change in size over a period of time. I don't think you should
debulk those tumors because it can cause it's too big of a surgery to go into the lungs and to
remove them and it's going to leave scar tissue, it's going to leave other things that's going to affect it.
So there's certain cancers that it's easier to debulk than other cancers.
Latter cancer, if I had bladder cancer on the inside wall of the bladder and you're going in with the
cystoscopy, the urologist has seen it and he's wanted, he did a biopsyde, I always wanted to go in and
remove that centimeter size tumor that is beneficial. So I would say yes, go ahead and debulk that,
that is that is the right thing to do for that case. So every cancer is a little bit different
but with breast cancer, you know, I understand, I know what I remove my breast, I don't want to do this
surgery if I can help it. Well, you can give yourself a little more time, you do want to look at your
blood tests to make sure that there isn't other complications that the bleeding is causing and if the
bleeding is getting better or worse, oh, it stayed the same over the last several months. Well,
again, we can't just keep bleeding and how much is going on. So those are the kind of things that we'd
have to look at and I'd gladly chat with you individually about that as well. So hopefully
a couple of those suggestions help. Okay, next question is not really a question, it's an announcement
regarding frequencies. Okay, I'm just remember I mentioned a while back that there's going to be new
breakthroughs coming through with the National Institute of Health able to glean frequencies off the
DNA of different cancers and the DNA of different pathogens that are causative factors of cancer.
Well, that has now come to fruition and by next week, I will be able to update a lot of people's
programs. Now, if you're doing, if you're using the right and you're doing well and your cancers
are really stable and you're doing great, you're going to be kind of put on the back burner doing
this, whether we need to do it or not. But if your cancer's growing like in the case of this person
with the breast cancer, cancer that's growing, but we're not getting the results that we really
want, and you're going to be put on the front burner or anybody else that their cancer is not going
to the right direction, your PSA is going up or whatever we need to do, you're going to be put on
the front burner and be updating your programs. So just know it won't be for another week or so,
I will be getting access to all the NIH websites, frequency sets, that we're going to be able to
create some updates to your programs. So you may be getting a flash drive from being within the next
two to three weeks. So if you get a flash drive, it'll give you, it will have the instructions.
And I'll talk about this on the next Zoom call and I'll put it on the member site. So I'll have
instructions on how to put it in your computer and to start running those frequencies. Now everybody
right now has your program as AA Sally Smith, and it has a date after it. So some people that have
been with me for years and years, they might not have the date after it. You're running a true right
program. And understand these NIH frequencies, I'm going to be able to use with the true right or the
and the artillery orbit. Now the artillery orbit is going to be more beneficial because we're going
to be able to run the 11th harmonic with these frequencies. So either one, they're going to be
beneficial. So they're specific suite programs that I'm creating from the NIH frequencies. So if I
send you that flash drive, then you'll start running that program. So do have AA your name,
and I'll have the date that I created the program. And you'll start using that program. Still be
you know, a weekly program with some short programs. And you could feel free to alternate between
your old program and this new program. But we could talk about that at some squint Zoom calls.
And I'll have information on the member site once and once those start going out.
So that is to be real good news. Understand, you know, my promise to you, when you started care
here was not that it was going to cure your cancer. I don't have that capability. I'm not a healer.
God is your healer. But God has given me wisdom. He's given me desire. Some people have called
Merida and said, you know, I don't want to start with Dr. Cutter's whole disease. What is he going to
retire? Okay, I'm never retiring. Okay, unless God takes me out of here. So my desire is to just continue
to do everything I possibly can to help my patients get better. I don't have any magic bullets. I don't
have any secret knowledge. I don't have any crystal ball. I rely on the Holy Spirit leading me to
as many different things as I possibly can. So when I do technology, anything that we can do to
improve the care that we're already giving, we're going to try to implement that.
So I will let you know with these, I'm super excited about these new frequencies.
They're updated on a fairly regular basis by the National Institute of Health. And they're not
right frequencies from the National Institute of Health. We're having to convert them. So they don't
give right frequencies, but they give DNA mitochondrial frequencies that we convert to right frequencies
to be able to create a program. So very exciting information. It's just another thing that could
possibly help a person get better. So I'll let you know what we're able to do that. Okay, questions
from the chat. First one, you mentioned I should stop taking my B vitamin supplements. I saw
some information about using organ meat supplements to replenish B vitamins when you have cancer.
Should I add that? You can. So can a cancer patient take organ meat organ supplements? The answer is
yes. Well, what if they have B vitamins? Yeah, that's fine. They don't have methyl B vitamins in them.
So it's the methyl groups in the B supplement that you can't have. Now we have the Seeking Health
brand of methyl free B complex. You could take that, but you could take organ supplements if you want
to. Designs for health has a really good organic organ combination. I think it's got five different
organs. It's called organ synergy. That is a good product that's in powder form and in capsule form.
It's from designs for health. We have it on our website. That's a good product.
It, you know, a lot of people are on supplement overload. They don't want to add anything else. I
get it. But the powdered organ product, you could throw in your smoothie super simple.
So that's the one I would recommend. My daughter uses that. Both my daughters, two of my daughters,
use that for their kids. They have her own in their smoothie or a daughter. Even what's that in
like a soup soups and stuff she makes. So her husband will take it. She doesn't tell him that she
puts it in there. But it's good. Second, next question. Is PEMF there? If the okay, if one has a
seizure disorder, okay. We were talking about PEMF therapy. And it's a great therapy. But there
are some drawbacks. So you can't use PEMF therapy if you have an electrical device implanted like
pacemaker. You can't use PEMF therapy if you have a seizure disorder. Well, you could if you didn't,
let's say on your feet or or something like that, but you'd have to be really careful.
So there's some things you can't do use PEMF therapy for because it's an electrical therapy.
So whereas the right is light frequencies of PEMF therapy is an electrical therapy and it could
throw off a pacemaker or something like that. So no, I wouldn't use it if I had a seizure disorder.
Next question. Clarification on the answer about the mosaic test. If I can't do it before I get
chemo tomorrow, should I wait and and tell when? I would just do it. So tomorrow's already Thursday.
No, tomorrow's. Yeah, tomorrow's already Thursday. I would wait until next Monday to do it.
Because you do want to set it out early in the week. So it's not at the post office over the weekend.
So just wait on Monday. That would be good. Next question. Is there a particular genetic
slip that has predisposed me to oxalate issues? Also, I have ordered the oxalate scavenger and
oxalate balancer with the scavenger B for when I am having a flare up and the balancer B daily.
Yes, that's typically how you use it. We do have patients that might typically make cancer
patients, but I have some genetic patients that do both of them on a daily basis. They just have
few different things in them. But yes, there are genetic steps for oxalate issues.
So I have to look at your genetics again. A person can have oxalate issues without having
oxalate gene defects. So remember, it's epigenetics that from genetics. However, most people that
have oxalate issues have oxalate gene defects. But we can look at that again if you want to set up
our post office. Next question. Recently, while watching a movie with my right, I must
have been the core going into the bulb that I got and it got really hot,
birdied hot, and it smelled like birdied electronics. After that, the bulb seems to be working
normally and not overheating. Was that just an auto-currence? Should I assume it's working properly?
Let's see if I have a picture here. Hold it. Maybe a second here or up.
Okay, here's the picture. Sorry, very loaded. Let's see if I can fold it down or my desktop.
Let's see if I can move it. There it is. Okay, so this, what I do, so I think what you're saying is
at the end, like where it connects to the bulb, to the inside of the bulb, that got bent and that got
hot right there. Is that what you're saying? Or is it that you bent it where it connects to the
rightful sheet itself? If you, let's use this first option, if you bent this and it got really hot
here, the danger is banging this or bending this can break the connection of these wires here.
I think you could see my cursor, right? These wires go in and this is an RF
blocker, so it's one of those RF shields, so that wire goes in and it connects
to the bulb itself. If that connection breaks, then the bulb isn't going to work.
So if that broke, then the bulb would not work anymore, so you didn't break that connection.
And if that connection breaks, then it's not fixable either. What I started doing with the bulbs,
and you could do this, I have a Velcro strip. So you're probably looking at this picture going,
my mom doesn't look like that. What is this black thing? But why is this looped here?
What is this black thing holding the cord there? Is that just for transport?
No, that is to prevent what you're saying. So we have recently got a number of people
act as to the last bud that are having their bulb not working. And as I got their bulb back,
it was broken. That connection where that wire goes in, and you can't see it behind this white
plastic thing, where the wire connects to the glass tube, this is just kind of packing material,
where it connects to the glass tube, that was broken. So what happened was the person must have
dropped the bulb and it landed on the end here, or the person was laid with it and it got
pulled inadvertently, didn't see that, or you rolled over and pulled it inadvertently, and it
broke that connection. And it looks perfectly fine. And it looks like there's nothing
wrong with the bulb. How come it doesn't work? And you could have just just broken that connection.
So I went back to, way back in the day, when Mike owned true right, what we used to do is zip tie
the bulb like this. Now I used Velcro straps. He used with him. We used two big black zip ties
and we looped the cord like this in black zip tie. You could use electrical tape, you could use duct tape,
whatever you want to do to hold the cord. So it gave a little slack here. So the cord has a little
bit of slack so that it helps prevent it getting pulled out. So if you accidentally pulled on it,
I rolled it over in batter, you pulled on it because you moved on, shifted on the culture, whatever,
it wouldn't pull that out. So this is the first time I'm making the suggestion that people do this.
It just gives added protection to the bulb. Now currently I'm sending all bulbs out like this,
with these Velcro straps. Will it help prevent damage? I think it will help.
Does it look goofy? I don't care if it looks goofy. I don't think you care if it looks goofy.
You want your bulb to last. You don't want to buy a new bulb. So I think doing that with your bulb
may help prevent exactly what you, I'm glad you asked this question because I was going to bring this
up and show this picture like completely forgot to add it to the slides today. And now see how
God works. So just make a loop like this, leave this loose, use duct tape or if you have Velcro straps
or if you have zip ties, however you want to do it, hold that down so that it will help at least give
some added protection of you pulling that cord out and could prolong the life of your bulb. So
I'm glad you got that up. Thank you. So if it is bad, if as long as the bulb is working, it's working.
So but just check and see that it's not keyed up the cord or something, just keep checking that.
Remember you can unmute yourself and ask a question verbally if you want or you can chat it in
a few questions. Welcome. All right. Well, you guys have a very blessed day and weekend. We are
getting a nice beautiful snowstorm right now. So I'm glad you're to keep praying for everybody and
make that your new love language to people that you're just going to make everybody a prayer
and you're made prayers that we become closer to our relationship to our angry father.
And that's what I'm praying for you. All right. God bless everybody.